elle a été créée en février 2021 mais
déjà reconnu dans le monde de
l'innovation road caire a été
sélectionné pour participer au spring
paris saclay le 20 et 21 mai prochains
cette start up est issu de l'entreprise
diagou est une société de diagnostic des
routes grâce à un camion et différents
dispositifs de mesure
roquet rapporte une nouvelle solution
innovante dans ce domaine routière est
une spin off de jag way et c'est la
version simplifiée du diagnostic routier
c'est à dire qu'on n'a pas besoin de
camions avec tous les équipements on a
juste besoin d'un smartphone d'une
application est la nouveauté c'est que
c'est également directement la
collectivité qui peut réaliser le
diagnostic en régie cette solution
facilite la gestion de la compétence
voirie pour les plus petites
collectivités locales l'utilisateur fixe
le téléphone sur le pare brise
il peut commencer son parcours les
routes étudiés sont captés à travers
l'application road caire nous on
récupère la donner il ya données
collectées et analysées sur nos serveurs
par l'intelligence artificielle
donc c'est là où tout l'inventaire se
fait des dégradations une poule les
fissures et toute la restitution se fait
ensuite sur sur une interface full web
donc le gestionnaire une fois de retour
au bureau se connecte avec son mail et a
accès à tous les menteurs des
dégradations qui est réalisé aux notes
de bons mauvais moyens et aussi au plan
de travaux que l'on propose suite à ce
diagnostic est pour le moment on est
capable de faire toutes ces briques
métier de notre côté en attendant que
l'application en ligne soit 100%
opérationnel sa participation au spring
paris saclay une chance pour votre coeur
d'accélérer son développement et prendre
la route du déploiement sur les marchés
publics